Hello, may I speak to Mrs. Jones, please?
I'm sorry, but Mrs. Jones isn't in at the moment.
May I ask who's calling?
Yes, my name is Kathy Jackson.
I spoke with her last week about the possibility of working there.
Kathy Jackson. Yes, I think I recognize your name.
Do you happen to know if your company is looking for anyone now?
I'm afraid I'm not the right person to ask about that.
You'll need to speak directly to Mrs. Jones.
But she can't answer the phone right now.
Okay, I understand. Well, could I leave a message for her, please?
Certainly. Is there a number that she can reach you at?
Actually, I don't have a number with me now.
I'll call back later.
Okay, I will give her the message that you will call back.
Thank you very much.